[Musique]
donc elisabeth bienvenue chez nous salut
merci merci à toi d'avoir accepté de
venir chez que tu donnes est pas mal
occupés j'imagine encore maintenant
c'est passé en ce moment c'est vraiment
mon temps mon lac huppé on est septembre
octobre et les mois les moins forts des
buts unis j'ai comme pas mal moins un
truc à faire puis toutes mes promotions
sont déjà booké pour novembre fait moi
je suis con mais est ce que tu es et ce
que tu es constamment en train de penser
à un autre idée à une prochaine un
prochain stade dans ton est bête tout le
temps ça toujours été soucieux jusque là
découragés comme tellement d'idées qui
est on s'entend qui émettent une idée
sur pied c'est plus long que d'avoir
l'idée et puis moi je suis quelqu'un
très focus tu es souvent les gens
mettront qu'ils partent en business et
souvent ils réussissent pas parce qu'ils
y ont plein d'idées en même temps puis
il commence unis commence l'odyssée
moitié jurant comme un à la fois tu
quand j'ai une idée je la change peu
chez focus s'est clos c'est sûr qu'il ya
des questions de fond de son âme
modifier des trucs là c'est vraiment ça
peut prendre des mois fait que je suis
un peu la dame puis j'ai comme j'ai
peut-être des idées pour jour trois ans
relève que je suis en train de
travailler dessus fétiche
en ce moment je comprends je peux pas
aller plus loin trois ans a maintenu ses
taux plus loin qu'ils aiment et et j'ai
d'autres business en ce moment sur l'ecc
est en train de travailler plutôt que de
parler ou ne peut pas parler
je peux en parler on sait que les
prochains et qui jettent un pont et
ouais ok dans le fond est la prochaine
les enfants avec laquelle je suis en
travailler c'est ma tante est la leur
bébé puis moi j'ai toujours été vraiment
passionné mais puis ben pour moi ce que
je m'étais dit c'est en ce moment les
générations d'instagram pitou où est ce
qu'on arrive c'est les les personnes à
la génération commence à avoir des
enfants
puis on voit déjà ça me semblait plus en
plus du jeu c'est ça puis il n'y a
encore aucune compagnie dans le fond de
vêtements pour bébés vraiment bien
installé son et sa g s'est tenue dans
moi mon but serait vraiment d'être les
premiers puis de mon ami d'adam puis
j'ai déjà été les plus grosses et insee
g us qui ont comme des enfants petite
soeur et je les ai déjà dans mes
ambassadeur de la caf et moi j'étais
déjà en contact avec lui puis du démon
prix des trucs comme ça c'est vraiment
une bonne des oui moi massa a le alors
c'est parti un blog à l'uqat enfants 5 1
c'est parti un blog où est ce qu'ils
racontent un petit peu les le d'étudier
dans une famille de quatre enfants
ça s'est passé quelque chose que le
monde 2.0 le mont sion qui grandit avec
les réseaux sociaux comme tu dis
commence à avoir des enfants
s'intéressent à ce genre de choses fait
une super bonne idée
c'est ça l'idée c'est attendre quitté
qui t'a donné énormément j'avais
travaillé
j'avais travaillé sur cette idée là avec
quelqu'un d'autre et on avait pu
travailler tous n'avaient plus comme
vraiment penser à l'idée notre concept
tout seul puis ma tante à m'écrire mon
est en deuil
j'ai une idée de business plutôt est ce
que tu voudrais venait chez moi puis la
personne
je les fuis fait clair on dit rien on
veut saisir planète ce plan n'est qu'en
mai je suis je vais déjà faire ce qu on
y va plus en plus la famille toufik
s'agisse vraiment bien a donné un paquet
on s'entend vraiment bien là dedans
c'est cool tu as vraiment une facilité
de soleil pour voir c'est quoi qu'est le
monde veulent ou sais quoi qui manque si
comme tu l'utilisés yapo encore sur
instagram ont offert c'est comment tu te
sens tu réfléchis où ça devient comment
que tout ça vient ce temps le suspense
viège kaka honnêtement en vie si je suis
vraiment besoin je comprends vraiment
bien les gens mangent tout à personne
c'est moi chez la personne qui est comme
acquis un pédophile je comprends qu est
ce qui se passe dans sa tête
toutefois le montant comme une ombre non
mais c'est quand même très très
empathique puis analyse beaucoup les
gens que je les comprends vraiment bien
mais moi mais tu es viré avec des gens
et ça marche pas en tout cas moi je suis
comme vraiment faire ce contrat mais non
si je sais pas pourquoi ça me touche
comme à l'énergie de façon il en est
venu ici pour le 10e addict avait
constamment d idée de comment monétiser
quelque chose comment qui te tombent une
sucette se refaire ce pitch vous donne
des conseils là dessus j'aimerais qui
comme à chaque fois mais tant que je
fais des call avec des compagnies et
mettons-nous yes page savoir un post
cohabiter des fois je le redis je suis
comme acquis mais moi mon public c'est
pas ton public sim pigeonnant peuple et
des fois je leur forme et de leur
business je leur dis quelle façon
l'emmener ces médias sociaux plus je
devienne conseiller awad à 421 m
d'habitants est une référence pour les
uns une conseillère à ce niveau là c'est
fort métier moi c'est je sais pas si tu
connais alexandre mots oui c'est dans le
fond on sort avec un gars avec qui j
danger qui était un de mes bons potes on
j'ai perdu un peu de vue et peu après
sur que en surtemps dos des tientas les
deux langues chèques et autres pour
optic donner des conseils de réseaux
sociaux j'avais aucune des puits ubot
theillet pas de formation c'est trop
nouveau encore y'a pas de formation pour
apprendre comment ça fonctionne fait le
monde qui ont fait comme toi qu'ils ont
appris sur le tas vous avez de loin la
connaissance qui ait peu de gens ont
honte vous avez appris comme sur le fait
puisque je pense pas que ça se
reproduise le porche ce que je pense que
je pensais pas aussi une façon de
chanter on est souvent membres demande
souvent d'aller faire des conférences
pitt ou de comment et un sourire du
sociaux puis j'aime pas se faire une
conférence je parle d'un groupe de
personne je leur dis comment faire parce
que les réseaux sociaux au bout de la
ligne tu le fais pas de la même façon
pour tout le monde présente pas un
produit de la même façon
ni une personne puis même dans le
timeline depuis tous ces thèmes
importants je peux te parler d'une façon
de faire les réseaux sociaux maintenant
pendant six mois ce serait la même en
face ça marcherait pas c'est comme le
timeline c'est quand même vraiment
vraiment important puisque l'important
est aussi changer ne pas rester dans le
même comme branding tout le temps mais
parce qu'elle a mené si on dit qu'une
influence sur fait 2.5 en métier c'est
vrai c'est comme avec un ca se démode
les gens ils les aiment les amis les
aime les mp demander si tu fais tout le
temps mais en face du champ jamais et le
menton juste comme amont et ses boules
il passe à autre chose si les gens
changent dans la vie pitino aussi en
tant que nous aussi en tant que les
personnes soient réseaux sociaux on
change puisque c'est important de
montrer ces changements si loin en tout
cas quand est arrivé on parlait de on
avait reçu françois lambert pitt avait
tenu son livre d'enfant ses livres puis
il disait qu'elle lui dans sa compagnie
à chaque 18 mois il faisait un meeting
pis réinventer puis il change la
direction mais maintenant c'est plus
haut depuis 18 mois ces genres toutes
les six semaines qui me demande combien
de temps avance mettons j'apprécie je
fais une promotion intrigant même si
comme moi c'est du jour au lendemain je
vois que saab est à fâches comme bon
laisser le moment puis je le fais pour
tous et comme il ya pas d c'est vraiment
fous que tu sois prêt à tout c'est fou
ce serait très sain pitt je commente et
des promotions tout tu vois vraiment la
fluctuation de la compagnie puis ce qui
est cool c'est que s'il ya beaucoup de
monde qui peuvent dire ce beaucoup
d'influenceurs que peuvent dire se sait
que tu es au service de toiles font
effectivement on compte instagram tu
t'en sers pourtant tombe rennes pour
t'accompagner fait que quand tu vois que
la compagnie a killer il ya une demande
nantaise dans tel secteur manquer tu
peux pousser avec une promo sur ton
compte à toi dans tel secteur ceci ça
pas de valeur le d'avoir eu les
capacités de pouvoir faire ce web et
c'est vraiment quelque chose que j'aime
de ne pas avoir à faire comme des spams
chercher avec des compagnies des trucs
de même parce que ce qui arrive souvent
c'est que il ya beaucoup d influence en
redire cent cinquante mille fois
quels mots on va doucement à date 6 mois
qui ne peut trouver le bon l'annoncé il
ya beaucoup de monde sur les réseaux
sociaux qui vivent de promotion et
publicité et d'intrigant même si ce qui
arrive c'est qu'il va m'emmener et
mettons est tu grossis la dentiste un
peu c'est un peu un cercle qui grossit
là dedans puis le typhon certain montant
d'argent en pouvant en ayant le pouvoir
de choisir des promotions puis en
faisant juste des trucs que tu aimes
puis tous pleurent un certain moment tu
un mode de vie en tant que telles puis
atterrit sociaux soit ea store ou soit
on voit les prix aussi qu'ils descendent
beaucoup avant qu'un métro marquis site
avant il fait faire 150 milles pour
impose qu'il y avait comme un million
d'abonnés tout de même jeu mais dans ce
temps là il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
monde qui va maintenant un million
d'abonnés 159 pts et c'est de plus en
plus parce que de plus en plus de
personnes qui sont populaires puis qui
font des publicités gratuites pour rien
et puis les gens ne savent pas comment
gérer ce donc
c'est comme un peu n'importe comment
puis ça fait que les prix de son nez
tout don comme on est suivi à un
certaine bonne de vie est une vie que de
ça puis tu fais plus l'argent dont on a
besoin pour payer la maison ton esprit
des enfants blabla secrètes se
retrouvent obligés à faire de la
publicité
tempus amant puis j'ai vu ce sujet
beaucoup de mes amis avec du temps et
que ça arrive et puis je continue quand
même chanceuse donné peuvent justement à
vorey avenir à ce moment là parce que
j'ai ma propre se pose pas de la chance
je pense que c'est clairement un
clairement a saisi une opportunité qui
était peut-être de cette version à toit
aussi c'est pas tout le monde que ce
soit c'est le l'esprit entrepreunarial
sur tout le monde que ce c'est ce que
rec et tout le monde se découvre les
gens ils essayent mais en fait pour tout
le monde c'est vraiment 95% des
compagnies 80% des compagnies ce que
françois lambert disaient qu'ils ferment
dans trois ans
comment sais tu te calmes 80% c'est du
monde qui met trois ans a quant à lui
c'est souvent parce que l'idée à la base
c'est pas une bonne idée effective il
attend d'avoir l'idée du siècle mais pas
les amendes attendre mais juste de
vraiment bien ciblé ton public ton idée
de ce qui est bonne parce qu'elle répond
ait besoin de ce nom
y'a juste pâte d'amande pitre fermé de
plantes mais si je pense tu le vois
dirait que ça marche pas tout moi je
sais pas si je pars quelque chose puis
un mois plus tard ça peut décoller plus
que ce jouet comme nex et en actions
comme trop attachés à leur idée
justement y en a qui il parlait aussi du
fait dans son livre qui est
il ya beaucoup de gens qui pensent que
ton idée doit être ta passion mais comme
pas nécessairement justement quand on
est 17,1 passion c'est là que tu es
vraiment attaché à ce puits quand on est
des mauvaises voies marche pas bien
s'éjecter plus de difficultés à ton
détaché la passion c'est
l'entrepreneuriat en alphonse et non ça
mais en même temps qu'ils y vont dire et
moi ma passion c'est le ski puis ils
vont se partir une graine de ski le ski
c'est comme mettez ça marche pas parce
que wever y en a plein aussi très chaud
dans le sens que les entrepreneurs sont
la base qui disait exemple c'est que
dans le fond sa passion lui c'est pas
nécessairement les lycées les centres
d'appels de ces faits qu'il s'est pas
les centres d'appels sa passion c'est le
fait d'avoir une business speed essayer
de l'amener à niveau toi comment est ce
que est ce que l'idée des maillots et
est venu parce que comme créton
following avec des photos en maillot
puis tu t'es dit c'est ça fit avec avec
le branding n'ont même pas je n'avais
pas vraiment de photos en maillot avant
avant de partir après compagnie de
maillots mais j'aimais faire des photos
de voyages d'erreurs que j'avais
l'occasion m'en faire puis mon but était
vraiment de voyage et je me dis à tes si
au moins je peux mettre mes voyages sur
ma business tout bas ça va juste comme
tout marché ensemble et en plus de ça va
me faire comme une raison de pommes
sentiment de dépenses pour voyage c'est
comme pour moi c'était jaidee parfait
puis je me dis ainsi comme un vêtement
se démode très vite tandis que maillot
de bain c'est facile de rendre un modèle
à la mode que ça respecte et qu'on voit
quand on fait comme plein cours à quito
puis si je suis le design qui est à la
mode un pilot maintenant tu voyages je
pense java tandis que ce voyage est
peut-être trop fois par mois après celle
associée
écoutez moi c'est comme la première
année oui parce que j'avais le temps
plutôt maintenant j'ai mes chiens fait
un peu plus
ouais je combats de repartir mais je
dirais peut-être deux fois par mois des
pôles ont tant pis quand tu voyages est
ce que tu peux vraiment profiter ton
voyage outils travailler tout le temps
piteux programme des voix robin de vivre
je vais moi depuis que je suis jeune
quand je fais quelque chose que ce soit
voyager aux gens j'aime vraiment prendre
des photos
c'est vraiment ce que j'aime puis comme
si je prend pas de photo on dirait que
j'ai partagé mon moment je ne sais pas
si c'est en étant le monde je déjeune
sur cinq est pour moi d'aller en voyage
pour m'asseoir en partant j'ai besoin
dans son sac pour aller en voyage façon
qu'on peut faire l'entrevue de bus mais
non c'est allé en voyage pour m'asseoir
ça va me stresser beaucoup plus que 3
des photos donc je dirais que je
travaille tout le temps chez genuity
sauf que c'est plus que prendre des
photos jobs tct le faire une fois dépose
enfin nancy en a pas tac
bref mettant à profit des témoignages ce
petit je profite de mes voyages piquer
mes voyages sont pas là non plus la
plupart du temps c'est du 3 5 juin qui
était sinon des gros voyage mais ton
léger un voyage de 8 jours à la fin du
mois mais si à moitié chez en estonie à
mon entrepôt puis l'autre moitié je suis
en norvège pour les photos au fait s'il
est un long voyage métissé vraiment
moitié que je suis dans mon entreprise
on envoie je prends des photos pour ak
ou non et ouais on n'aurait jamais dû
voir mais ça va être la thématique on
s'envoie s'est gelé un peu n'ont cessé
jeudi chaloupés roupies mais c'est pas
joli à ce moment les faits commencent
eyskens hockey non ça s'avère mois au
pérou s'était aussi l'histoire de
montagne avait il y avait
c'est tellement des beaux paysages
ferrand de la plage puis des décors
qu'on voudrait c'est celle que nous
autres on a commencé à faire dans ce cas
enfin on fait on fait des fois des gates
et puis 406 100 piasses type là on voit
pas si tu es gay volé à toi ce que tu
donnes un voyage streda pas désabonner
leucine scène devoir faire simple c'est
que tu le fais pour vrai qu avec les
hanter party bjp avait une gagnante je
pense qu'il est avec vous autres en
jamais toi mais ça c'est fou comme c'est
tu donnes un voyage suédoise juste parce
que tu veux
tickets souvent les compagnies vont
amener des modèles puis des trucs en
voyage pour faire leurs photos de leur
compagnie new cities et des voyages
photo / qu'on a beaucoup plu ont fait
vrombir actif des pitot mais on fait
aussi des photos seins puis nous
accueillent tant d'années que le
branding c'est vraiment tout le monde
peut être un modèle pour oi c'est super
cool tout les types de codes n'importe
qui donc on se dit n'est portée qui peut
faire les photos donc pourquoi pas en
plus de ses fringues ivory ce qui nous
ramène aussi de la visibilité mais qui
donne aussi à n'importe qui d'avoir la
chance au hasard de venir avec nous en
voyage donc puis qui va apparaître sur
les photos si on oublie que ça prouve
justement que c'est tout le monde veut
des clients deviennent des modèles ça
inclut les clients dans la démarche pis
je ne sais qu'il fait aussi que les gens
sentent investis là dedans le brent non
c'est tout le monde est vraiment élevé
sinon on est comme tout ensemble sur une
petite amie grosse amis c'est vraiment
cool puis là je demande ce voyage là hop
et roule
est ce qui te vous êtes allés au bond
les voyons la petite villa mont lachaux
pitch on faisait le machu picchu sacs à
main les matches futurs
ouais mais ton pour tout le vécu comme
un plat machu picchu c'était vraiment
touristique surtout comparativement à ce
qu'on avait fait avant d'en pirou mai
mais je dis c'est le fun c'est twilight
mais honnêtement du pérou se pressent à
l'addition que c'est vraiment vraiment
beau mais je pense que moi là du pire où
ç'a vraiment été les gens mais qui sont
les meilleures personnes que j'ai
rencontrées
schaller a passé aussi pied je peux
confirmer
ouais non c'est vraiment des bonnes
personnes puis sont extrêmement ouvert
d'esprit mais dans les villages éloignés
que ça puisse était vraiment et sont
vraiment intéressés et intéressants
c'est cool ça c'est vraiment les
cultures différentes que tu découvres en
voyage qui nous autres on veut repartir
en voyage
ben vite mais on trouve juste pas le
temps de faire mais c'est vrai les
cultures quand ils découvrent qu'ils
font que quand tu reviens ici des comme
encore chez qui un public je pensais tu
fais ça tout sport quand même souvent
fait que je sais tu fais ça à chaque
fois c'est comme un péché qui peut
nécessairement je disais ça dépend où
est-ce que tu voyages mais je suis
jamais allé à quelques ports lorsque je
suis allé une fois qui porte sa vraiment
plus ce chéquier dans ce sens que les
conditions de vie étaient pas vraiment
bonne qui était en inde à mumbai
mais à part de ce oui des fois tu vas
des endroits c'est moins preuve c'est
plus les gens vivent dans les toits de
tôle des trucs comme ça mais moi je
pense qu'avec moi je veux un peu vécu
les deux dans le genre grosse mes
parents n'avaient pas d'argent plutôt
puis maintenant comme on ne peut pas mal
plus d'argent puis je sais que c'est pas
quelque chose que je compte ça n'a
aucune valeur l'enfant pour moi quand je
voyage je suis vraiment capable de voir
au delà de ça je le remarque même pas
puis et moi c'est vraiment le bonheur
des gens pillaient si je pense que juste
à mon bac s j'ai eu l'impression que les
gens étaient peinés sûrement heureux
apports de sel je trouve que souvent les
gens dans les pays qui ont peut-être
moins de moyens que nous ont souvent là
beaucoup plusieurs quais moi je suis
jamais revenue comme chez qui le ch
comme j'ai pas en allant les suivants y
en a qui disent c'est des fois j'emmène
justement des gones niveau et qu'on peut
les semble pouvoir agir tout sens commun
ils font petits devraient venus dans le
pays bas en europe ce qu'annonce on sont
tellement mieux ils sont un million
petit risque puis on peut suivre le bon
environ facile à ces gens là c'est les
gens d'aller dans des milieux vraiment
ou dans des pays vraiment défavorisés
c'est qu'ils voient pauvres ils voient
pas maintenant
quelqu'un qui est pauvre au québec voit
les riches au québec puis tu vois le
style de vie du monde moyens mais tu
fuck thx et le ch malheureux parce que
j'ai pas sauter mais dans ces pays là
c'est qu'ils vouent leur référence c'est
tout le monde autour d'outils fait
qu'ils se font du bonheur avec ce qu'ils
ont autour d'eux puis sidaction met
vraiment en perspective le matériel je
pense que c'est je pense que je suis
passé des études là dessus mais que le
bonheur c'est si beaucoup dans les
relations interpersonnelles que tu avec
les autres peut avoir plein d'affaires
ou tout ce que tu pense qu'ils vont
amener de bonheur mais c'est au pas des
relations fortes bonne scène avec ta
famille des gens autour de toi des amis
ça ne donne pas grand chose je pense le
bonheur c'est fou différents pour tout
le monde c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui
vont sûrement trouver leur bonheur dans
la richesse puis dans les trucs de même
été c'est pas tout le monde puis
honnêtement c'est une question où est ce
que tu te sens différente plus plus
heureusement heureuse qui aimait tant
voulu aussi sans doute la même personne
ça changerait je dirais que le moment
que j'ai été le plus heureux
ça a été comme un business à la grotte
avoir le sentiment que tu fais comme
grandi quelque chose que ça va vite que
les gens aiment ce pitou qui maintenant
qu'elle se rende
on dirait que quand tu es en voie
d'avoir est ce que tu penses qu'ils
voteront erreur c'est là que tu es
heureux parce qu'il sent que ça vient au
moment qui arrive tu te rends compte que
c'est pas vraiment ce qui trancherait
c'est là qu'ils étaient comme un genre
de dante facile processus puisque le
point d'arriver finalement c'est le
sentiment qui est quelque chose qui te
crie qui grandit
non c'est sûr c'était d'avoir les
sentiments du temps quelque chose de
nouveau qui arrive comme moi je me dois
vraiment ce qui maintenant que j'ai tout
ce que j'ai toujours voulu comme bon
c'est quoi ces choses j'ai toujours
voulu quitter manas d'été moi je voulais
ma maison avec mes chiens j'arrive j'ai
ma maison j'ai mes chiens je suis très
content d'avoir mes chiens c'est comme
mon
et je voulais vraiment voyager
maintenant je suis comme rendu mais pas
tannés de voyager mais j'ai le goût est
en béton armé chez moi j'ai vu d'avoir
un enfant mais juste deux compagnons
pour répondre et j'ai l'impression que
dans ma vie chaque homme rendu la gauche
avait 19 ans et puis j'ai pensé
connaissances pour demain matin métier
moi mon estime dit dans 15 ans surnom
genre aucune chance que ça arrive dans
15 ans c'est que non si on dirait que on
dirait que là que je suis prête à
quelque chose de nouveau qui est
aucunement rapport avec la carrière
l'argent mort vers mais que je suis
juste pas en mesure de me rendre
l'affection que je me sens un peu story
mais bon si vous trouvez la spa est
hyper cintrée ça ça me ramène un point
que je voulais qu'on parlait avec toi le
évidemment les deux dernières semaines
une thématique qui revient quand compte
suite one puis puis ça c'est une
question que nous avec gestion se
trouvent souvent basket en coupe dans
l'oeil du public c'est quand même c'est
quand même triki ouais parce que des
chicanes ils peuvent faire un serment
apparaître au grand jour
t les moments que ça en moins bien et
les moments aider à faire des fautes
cinq ans contre eux à deux puits
éventuellement tu veux tu une t'aimerai
mieux ne pas finir le contrat de metsu
le signer type c'est un nom qui là
dessus les autres jesse signe un contrat
ouais on a fait une souris on a fait non
impossible contre ensemble on a fait ce
qu'il veut de trucs qu'on signe un
contrat à deux puis éventuellement aux
diamants n'ont pas la même vision de ce
qu'on en fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait plus
vraiment une fille ni petites foulées
dire on signe un conte rock et on est en
couple officiellement claque on signe un
contrat non non nous allons pas fait
chez que sa section
ça existe et je pense qu'à l'époque je
vaux de la question parce qu'il ya
alexandre m'a même dit que des fois ça
se faisait le des contres pour être sûr
de peau ne pas que ça casse en plein
milieu mais je suis pas une compagnie
qui enjambait me tourne justice et qu'on
avait le site et on avait des pauses
prévu près de septembre à novembre piste
est comme poulet est ensemble pour ce
qui fait que jusqu'à novembre faut que
publiquement vous attend son équipe mais
ça faisait quand même temps que vous
étiez plus ensemble et en avril contre
un mais aurait fait se trouvent ceux du
sud d'être exposé à l'expliquent
constamment puis que peu importe qu est
ce que tu vas faire ça va toujours être
pris par quelqu'un repris quelques ports
peu importe qu'il sera pas pour ta vie
personnelle de vie amoureuse c'est ce
qui est dur c'est qui est sur les médias
sociaux souvent tu t'exposes chante à
vue personnel puis par exemple j'ai
beaucoup gros de mon coach haut-rhinois
mais peut descendre maintenant mais
l'année avant ainsi que tu moi ce qui me
passionnait c'était mon chum puis mes
voyages fait que je suis je me teste -
c'est grand pigeon scoré que c'est beau
et puis on prend des photos ensemble
gros bras qui le petit gros foule pour
ce prix les gens items pour ce petit bla
bla bla à mener tu arrives à un certain
moment de ta vie que tu veux changer
que ce soit des gens qui veulent changer
de personnalité ou bien un couple qui se
sépare
puis le et sam ça devient ta carrière
parce que totalement gros de ce que ça
devient comme très très important dans
ta vie même s'il ya des gens pour qui
c'est difficile d'y penser mais ça
devient hyper important parce que
et c'est ta job je déteste loyer à payer
des chiens à nourrir la bourse à table
non mais c'est sa petite est incertain
et modes de vie
tout pilote arrive à ce moment là où
normalement dans ta vie tu changes puis
les gens les témoins ils veulent moi ya
jeté une ombre bla bla puis c'est sûr
que ça fait mal parce que c'était comme
un peut pas nier la danse et moi j'ai
des amis qui viennent los angeles
elle a été vraiment connu parce qu'il a
fait une dépression puis a parlé tout
temps dessus sur youtube tout puis à
partir du moment où elle saute sa
dépression ça a pris près de deux ans et
s'était rendu à qom 3.5 millions sur
youtube de substrats beurre puis il y
avait vraiment comme le sujet parce
qu'elle fait d'une façon humoristique
gros bras play était besoin de force de
sa vie qu'il se sentait vraiment plus
confiante pilati a commencé je sais pas
parler d'autres sujets et puis a juste
montré qu'ils étaient était bien et est
confiant de voir brad pitt y en avait
plein de commentaires puis tout le monde
a la une ce script où tout était
tellement mieux quand tu étais et
gadgets et son nom mais gentil tu es
tellement mieux quand il était cette
personne le bluegrass et comme c'était
pas heureux pour moi et j'ai sorti les
c'est que soient malheureux tati se pile
quand tout va mieux ça des centres ifo
qui nécessite un concept qui est
extrêmement intéressant de dire suite
créé un fort loin basé sur une image qui
te met n'importe qui d'autre que
personne qui les suit dans leur vie
peuvent prendre une décision de changer
n'importe quand mais tout est rendu
comme c'est le cas chez toi je pars pas
toi je mange la tt comme rendus esclaves
du following que tu t'es cru mais c'est
ceci qui m'attend ce qu'un acteur ou de
quoi qui tu sors avec quelqu'un pitt ses
parts dans vite et encore acteur genre
ça changerait pas ton certains petits
bagages la des films parce qu'il est en
couple avec 6 à pisser camps bay ont de
quoi peut-être mais quand tu es au bout
de l'allée jeu de légende connaissent
pas pour ta vie personnelle je parle pas
juste d'un coup mais ça peut être
n'importe quoi puis les jeunes
connaissent pas pour ta vie personnelle
donc ce que tu fais dans ta vie
personnelle sata partie encore tandis
que caen tc médias sociaux puis c'est ta
vie personnelle pour laquelle tu es aimé
si c'est pas beau pendant le moment
parce que tu vis quelque chose que tu
aimes puis les gens aiment ce peace qui
monétise donc c'est merveilleux c'est le
meilleur truc qui peut t'arriver sauf
qu'à partir du jour où il décide de
changer puisse et puis c'est ta vie
personnelle que les gens aiment put avis
personnel bah tu fais quoi tu es tu dois
être quelqu'un d'autre faire quelque
chose autre petite île inverse existe
aussi exemple marque seat qui était
super connu pour le fitness pitou lui ce
qui le passionne c'est le fitness et
puis après c'est tout le monde a
commencé à être dans le site nice plus
que tout le monde est dans le tennis
mais lui était vraiment d'un pionnier
rémy plus pour ceux que ça va marcher
c'est maintenant tu es iglo pu vraiment
puis comme si ça va pas aussi vite
qu'avant puis parce qu'il ya comme trop
dense que 22 membres
mais lui il n'y a pas envie de changer
je dis c'est lui ce qui s'est dit ou
cinq ans mais il devrait changer pour
continuer à grossir pour continuer à
grosses et métiers jeudi sa personnalité
pas de changer du tout au tout pour nos
personnes non plus il montre suisse
casquette parce qu'il ya la pression que
c'est lui reloue société épi nécessaire
pic était environ 17 heures à raison
maison puis est ce que toi tu as changé
un moment donné mettons dans les îles
les années où est ce que tu fais c'est
ce qu'a en es tu t'es dit qui est là
j'ai plus envie de faire et que ça à
faire et je veux commencer à faire sur
pie advienne que pourra pour mes abonnés
mais au début je faisais plus en plus
sexy ou a révélé mais comme si j'allais
faire des photos je peux demander c'est
pas vraiment osé sextiae mais lorsque je
peux comment l'expliquez puis amendé et
je me souviens avoir comme au capitou
plancher comme et qui mélange doit
censurer un peu plus s'ils arrachent un
peu plus comme ils ont le temps comment
n'ai je vais choquer je dois un peu plus
censurer mais pose pour bien paraître
pour m'accompagner pis tout petit
c'était pas nécessairement jetez pas
fake ou de quoi jeter mois mais juste un
peu plus censurer certaines choses
certaines choses que j'allais garder
pour moi ou certaines photos que j'avais
peur
puis ça a été comme ça pendant vraiment
longtemps puis après ça
c'est sûr qu'ils sont tous aussi des
changements qui qui se comptent sur un
100m puis après ça maintenant je suis
rendu que je lui revenir
- comme avant puis je perdrais le monde
que je perdrais ou chevalerie tous cas
je gagnerai plus et où puis je vous de
mettre une photo osée puis cech et le
monde un peu fait avoir commencé à des
censures et voici s'est tranquillement
je laissais je suis je pose des vidéos
de cacaoyers tout c'est quoi c'est quoi
l'idée puis en fait en fait c'est quoi
la question que je me pose est si tu le
fais mes frais d'ape en français tu es
là bas français en dix ans probablement
faut que tu sois j'espère une vidéo qui
raconte une histoire sexy quoi le
processus parce que ça c'est le trend
est sur youtube puis pour traîner sur
youtube faut que ça faut que ça ait du
de l'attrait il faut que l'allemagne et
deux films en vidéo et avec un de mes
amis qui étaient là on livre secret
on livre secret war se crée tout de même
pu commencer venue à ce sommet qui a
envoyé une histoire de pipi caca aps le
shaker sommes aussi j'en ai une le che
comme as trop long à raconter il
faudrait qu'on fasse un storytelling
place jean-moulin que l'anti des eaux la
plante et comment oui on fait ce plan
est filmé cette vidéo le spontané mais
j'avoue qu'ils étaient pour des
storytelling des trucs comme ça j'aime
mieux parle en français parce que c'est
ma première langue c'est qui est en
anglais c'est un peu plus en fait j pas
laissant fuir la misère pendant en
anglais un peu mais comme tu peux pas
non plus mais c'est vraiment pour est
séquencée des vidéos humoristiques
ils disent que t'es blind complètement
notre langue mais d'ailleurs c'est
youtube ça fait longtemps que tu as fait
des vidéos sur youtube c'est plus
nouveau et ça fait longtemps que je
pense des vidéos mais à une fréquence
très tôt quel genre vidéo trois mois
puisque je faisais pas youtube le chef
du tout mais parce que leur récemment tu
as fait plus simple
et oui dans le fond moi j'aime vraiment
ce film et les vidéos que j'ai un
milliard des millions de vidéos dans mon
téléphone jour développe des trucs genre
des fois je suis qu'à ma gastro
intéressant chemin vidéo puis jésus déjà
mais ça ne m'arrive pas parce que j'ai
pas le temps puis c'est long les détient
vidéo puis bgl mes amis que lui dans le
fond ils ne savaient pas et beaucoup
d'argent qui s'adapte au pays se plaît
j'ai proposé à baptiste vous pourrez
éditer mes vidéos moi je m'en foutiste
des tout mon argent d'adsense team est
déjà trop vidéo par semaine puis quand
on commence à mener que si jack pot qui
fait 60 millions par année et prend les
60 millions c'est comme moi je le ferai
pas si t'es pas le sait que jamais comme
james bond mais je les connais
ouais c'était juste quand même te
prendre l'argent de mme watson c'est
excitant c'est plus un truc plus
d'argent passer ta compagnie fonctionne
tellement bien que t'as pas besoin de
façon à fond tu fais vraiment pour le
fun
ouais c'est ça pis si je me dis
lui ça il se plaisait ça va faire rage
en plus tôt et au bout de la ligne
le plus gros de la dope je trouve ces
détails ci mais moi ça m'a aidé à un peu
plus canal du côté de youtube pour faire
ma compagne est aussi je pense et je
gagne tout le temps d'adapter de la
compagnie toi dans le fond est reconnu
pour être connu ce puits mettons titouan
la tv c'est pas quelque chose qui te
fait quand même pas mal mais non s'agit
pas ici mais est-ce que aux hackers pour
revenir accompagné ce que tu vois que ce
qui ça continue à agrandir un rythme qui
ressemble à l'expansion initiale ou
est-ce que ça le ralenti un petit peu en
termes patients peuvent en infinie de
maillots mais un meilleur monde qui
contiennent des maillots et connaissent
puisqu'ils connaissent accompagné comme
un espèce de deux points que tu peux 30
gb c'est ça c'est que souvent les gens
qui sont des influences qui se parlent
des compagnies vont s'arrêter alors
public qui m'est témoin je t'ai pas
passion les influenceurs grosse partie
des compagnies pour dire que son
entrepreneur parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
qui sont connus pour être connu
justement puisque ceux connaissant
pourra vendre compagnie mais si j'ai une
compagnie j'ai plus de crédibilité fait
qu'ils vont en faire parce qu'ils ont la
piste à ce moment là que ça flop que ça
marche pas vraiment puis dans le fond si
c'est moi quand j'ai commencé ma
compagne et c'était pas juste c'est moi
je me disais je t'ai juste comme un air
de quelque chose mais si j'ai beaucoup
de contacts à los angeles plus tôt j'ai
beaucoup d'autres influences sont à
l'international donc c'est vraiment et
si je me suis pas arrêtée à moi loin de
là pour les abonnés de wasquehal moi
juste une partie de s'appuyer
si ça vient de plein d'autres
personnages en effet le public et est ce
que tu as déjà essayé ou tu voudrais
sortir de instagram youtube internet
pour rejoindre les gens qui sont juste
pas connectés ou basse et s'avoue juste
plus la peine en 2018 de façon c'est
dans des métiers traditionnels ou
vraiment aimé ton qui postent à grand
piquey mikit c'est sûr que le sizing
haut à castres on peut décemment 7 juin
une femme de 40 ans un maillot de bain
aux mêmes places qui moi une fille de
six ans
sexto plus le même truc ça match parce
que je sais que ça ferait public c'est
les jeunes que les jeunes sont sur
instagram
mais là on est dit on est des gens qui
travaillent avec nous en ce moment pour
facebook puis on va commencer comme
plusieurs campagnes sur facebook qui
vont faire justement qu'est mon jeu a
dit à chine mais moi personnellement
j'étais un peu plus détaché sur mon
profil tu vas voir que ses écrits
honneur de waka soir messi va se revoir
ce voyage c'est pas écrit que c'est moi
qui ai pas de photos de moi fait que
c'est comme si je détache au haka de moi
mettez moi je continue à faire la paix
moi je crois que j'ai un peu comme
d'influenceurs doigt quand on est un peu
comme des influences tu fais à fond sur
son propre profil qui parle de facebook
chez que l'algorithme a changé récemment
pour facebook pour les pages surtout
deux compagnies de bus
c'est plus dur avoir un risque et que tu
tellement pêche en fait un cas comme je
peux sur facebook vendues depuis le
monde qui vont le faire pour nous
justement si je gardais mon et la tuque
doute on est une équipe on travaille
ensemble mais c'est des pros de facebook
ait eu d'enfant lyon parti en compagnie
facebook puis ça comme vraiment marchés
publics elle s'occupait de nous notre
facebook perfection mais est-ce que
c'est inquiétant d'être un peu à la
merci d'un réseau social qui ne contrôle
pas vraiment les réalités saint-agrève
décide qui change la grille donc je
change de quelque chose et que ça peut
affecter la compagnie des revenus de
ceux est ce que ce n'est que tout pour
toi ou pas vraiment où est ce que cette
inquiétude pour la compagnie mais
connaissant pour moi dans ce sens qu'ils
étaient j'ai vraiment apprécié par un
public
moi si je suis pauvre demain matin bien
gardé ses méthodes de même attaché plus
tard jean biancucci à économiser mes
gros ce que j'ai dans mon compte ne
manque en ce moment puis je me trouve un
job un chercheur de la neige changeante
certaine
et c'est comme tu est une question un
peu nous non sens que genre il y en a
sûrement qui disent oui mais une fille
mais sans instagram est plus rien c'est
comme ben oui pigeon un policier son
loyer pourriez quand je sais comme c'est
oui les réseaux sociaux s aggravent va
partir comme ça va arriver c'est juste
d'être le seul prochain ou de toute
façon le j'imagine que même si sa g
plantées çà arrive au repos les la
compagnie quand même ce sera considéré
de rouler sur moi pareil non c'est la
compagne rejet c'est sûr que ça ferait
mal et à l'accompagner mais ça continue
de rouler pareil puis été commis juste
[Musique]
ton objectif c'est de devant tuellement
je disparais de la place publique toi en
tant que que les abeilles et je ne sais
pas pour je sais pas j'étais moins de
médium c'est sam hamad
oui c'était quoi la formulation je me
gêne cap a du souffle à son public pour
laisser place à une combustion spontanée
non
en fait si on avait une médium système
en pièces et fou j'en ai dit des trucs
de notre passé quand elle sait pas en
équipe et avec d'autres amis qui sont
vraiment peu connus pigeons qui est a
dit que j'allais vivre une période très
très noir pendant longtemps puis cap si
j'allais disparaître puis j'allais
revenir plus tard dans ma vie le temps
cette période il s'est placé très grave
est ce que tu fais c'est souvent le seco
statut à vegas est allé boire de médium
où c'était annoncé c'est ici que c'est
quelque chose que tu fais sur la foi de
premières photos que j'avais fait lire
les mêmes s'étaient jamais fait c'est
rocard non c'est après qu'ils mettent
comme une crédibilité tout donner ce
genre 100 % ou ttg métro mais avant
j'étais vraiment mitigée
puis après ce pour vrai le genre al
tellement donné des trucs du genre foule
précis mettons une de mes amies en ce
moment après quand un gosse joue un
policier puis je leur ai dit yang dans
ta vie il plus jeune que toi et blanc si
un gars en uniforme de travail genre
pour le gouvernement quelque chose de
même a dit lui a vraiment beaucoup
d'amour pour toi puis tu sois vivent un
beau voyage avec lui vous allez être
ensemble longtemps mais ça va très très
mal se finir
elle était comme avoir un policier lève
tout quoi tout était comme à la bobine
ont observé à propos des stocks et je
n'ai plus mes jambes mes amis le genre
0,38
pitau dit quelqu'un qui est bonne pour
lire le monde pense tu que elle s'est
juste est vraiment vraiment bonne pour
l'irlande moi je peux lire qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent
l'implant les connaissent un peu que
j'arrive jeux comme halo mettez en
regardant leur comportement victimes
étaient des femmes et des hommes est ce
que tu penses que c'est un monsieur
c'est une bonne question ce que moi ça
ça me fait capoter ces affaires là je
suis jamais sûr de la limite de comme de
dire quelque chose de trop générique qui
est tout simple et ça c'est moi j'en
obtiens il ya des affaires ultra précis
j'ai toujours eu la mauvaise idée
extrêmement sceptique et fo aussi c'est
que nous on était trois fils jean qui se
faisait faire puis follet j'embrasse les
cartes en faisant le plein puis on le
disait peu mon ami à la demande et genre
est ce qu avait rencontré l'amour de sa
vie qu'il parlait d'amour tout le long
et mon hôte a mis à le demander pour sa
carrière tout le long et est comme ça
aux dix neuf d'argent blabla mais elle
savait pas le genre aucune des deux
qu'est ce qu'on nous demande d'en tête
moi j'ai demandé est ce que j'aurai
trust sans parler de la maison j'ai des
trucs comme un gros blanc puis comme
c'était foule priscilla nous parle
exactement de notre ville qui ont exigé
de notre vie à la fin qu'on avait fini
c'était comme comment les gens vont
compenser cette tendance que c'est
vraiment bizarre
c'est ça ma vraie entre mathieu dumas
est moche et qu'il faudrait que je le
vivais en essayant ni romaine j'avais
fait ça serait ça serait marrant moi
j'ai ma mère avait dieu aime à parler tu
allais vont rencontrer une fille a dit
que c'était une petite fille l'avait
jarre 15 ans mais c'est comment seule
chine ses amis je retrouve une
connaissance d'une connaissance que tout
le monde dans le village savait que
cette petite fille élève un don c'est le
mans maritale et lavaur plat parents
actifs est assez miami genre de rush de
même en noir a laminé deuxième roche
dans ses mains et il pleut et et attin
même plus poussées yeux sont comme
participant à l'arrière et puis la ceni
hadja raconter des histoires lh2 comme
des vies antérieures de ma mère
tellement ma mère
a senti que ses vies antérieures était
comme ça faisait tellement du sens tout
ce qu'a dit elle a juste fait plonger
tout le monde s'est mis à pleurer en
place neuf mois quand ma mère m'a
conduit j'y crois pas pantoute
après ça j'arrive à occupation d'hommes
il faut faire une séance de yoga mendel
je me déchire en larmes jaffrain de la
faire parce que il y avait que l'hydro
d'énergie des hommes puis comme qu'est
ce qui vient de se passer est une
affaire de médium ou de postaux dans le
yoga mandat le nom mais c'est comme sur
fallait que tu regardes les yeux d'une
personne que tout est intense au niveau
de quitter leur procès s'était cas de
bien lire les gens parce que au regard
des genres dirais qu'au fond des yeux de
la personne
puis le tas comme l'impression d'avoir
toutes les espèces de thons la marre des
gens qui tombait dessus savez que j'ai
fait un screenshot de haut et de larmes
les gens envoyés salafis d'audi mais ça
sur instagram à péage se plaît ça vaut
la peine
ces premières photos mais non mais je
sais mais faut que tu essaies même aussi
jeter comme sceptique mais j'aimais y
croire puis finalement c'est comme gens
m'apprécient c'est quoi comme trop
générale que genre elle aurait pu dire
n'importe quoi ou quelque chose mais ça
peut être pressent aussi le genre d'y
emmener mes amis a dit jean je vois
qu'une très très très très très très
très mauvaises nouvelles qui arrivent
qui va être dit ok tu as vraiment
beaucoup souffrir de ce qu'ils avaient
coûté très cher ça va te casier ni un
déménagement tisser comme fou le
principe est habité tout qu'est ce que
je vous dis nottellet puis vous allez le
voir gens qui savent armée comme si tu
reviens leur jardin six mois puis on
sait que si c'est arrivé c'est bon c'est
bon on est historique
on s'enfonce à se parler pour que pour
moi c'est arrivé mais totti noté des
affaires génétique mais comme tu es chez
que je peux rencontrer l'amour de ma vie
en voyage un voyage les façons dont les
gens sont très bonnes il vient pas d'ici
un australien ben ali n'est pas assez
précis qui va avoir un enfant pas si
pire bientôt qu'aimer peu genre était
comme il a su que j avais parlé du fait
qu tu avais hâte d'avoir des enfants
clip qui est un être comme je comprends
pas pourquoi mais des fois samedi
bientôt des fois ça ne peut bientôt mais
moi je sais comme parce que moi dans ma
tête se dit je vais avoir un enfant dans
deux ans pour moi c'est pas bientôt mais
pour elle c'est sûrement bientôt fixé
sur mon jeu comme souvent pour ceux qui
mélangent et c'est bientôt pas bientôt
parce que pour toi deux ans adressé au
moins c'est pas bien pour moi cela me
donne à fond alors que pendant deux ans
qu'ils convainquent un but sur un contre
le père de temps j'ai une amie de la
famille qui fait ce puits est super
heureuse je la trouvais pas de retour et
pas de tuer ma trouvait pas de quoi
former à la prime ou son sperme pièce il
est des banques qui peut tacher depuis
que tu as le choix aujourd'hui la
génétique que tu veux pour si peu avant
et tu peux avoir des des papiers avec la
personne j'avais regardé en boucle soit
2 foot est quelqu'un qui côtoie coûté un
conjoint de fait les gens je trouve que
mais tu peux te faire inséminer
sexuelles dans ce moule qui fonçait mais
oui mais en mai
non sa pige pas mais apparemment qui
jure avoir un enfant c'est bon mais ça
vaut la peine d'attendre
ça vaut la peine d'y croire fait si tu y
crois ça vaut la peine d'attendre sucre
au pôle m'a dit si je prends un papier
que j'écris exactement mon homme idéal
si lui que je vais rencontrer je veux
vraiment rencontré l'homme idéal qui
était dans ta tête a dit prends papier
toutes les enfants que tu veuilles
dessus puis se rend compte que le fait
non encore faire ce pour quoi il mais ô
combien ton âme d un peu c'est pas dit
blanc est loin la personnalité
évidemment et bien évidemment évidemment
à cfoot mais intéressait vraiment cool
pierre puis m'ont dit ça fait faire par
raimondi un homme aux cheveux vraiment
foncer il plus vieux que toi il t'aime
vraiment beaucoup
ces dames opposera mort et sexuelle
j'en sais beaucoup d'amour vraiment
intense mais it manipule dans ton dos
peer 6 pts avait foule le pen a lui
aussi pu genre toi aussi satisfait le
pen mais genre mitaine pour de vrai mais
il fait du mal mais tout peut être
découvert sur pied bien dans sa peau est
ce que tu es ce que tu es non mais on a
eu un doute
par rapport à la manipulation dans ton
doux est ce que tu peux douter de ckoi
je sais quoi mais j'ai laissé pigeard
démons halimi les duos inédits réussi à
le faire et puis ça dit il ya une blonde
aux yeux bleus autour de toi ap la cote
dans ton dos puis à votre faim un gros
combat mais tu t'y attends déjà pas ce
qu'a fait ça tout le monde savoure ce
qui m'émeut lydia sa veste équine
c'est fou vendu on les voit partout
non ça va pas si un médium ici s'il vous
plaît écrivez à 100 fait podcast
gmail.com pour une chose d'un point de
fausses vraies de vraies puis on veut
des certifications je sais pas si ça
existe en charge et sa double ok c'est
pas sa job qui fait envie on dirait que
le montrer que j'y crois plus tôt 1 cuil
pourquoi parce que si tu montes c'est un
business puisque ça pour faire de
l'argent
ça sonne plus là c'est bien mais si en
même temps du monde qui ont qui ont des
pouvoirs pied au delà de ce qu'ils on
devrait avoir une semaine oui mais même
ça serait fou les smarts matin et ont
pas de casse toi mais c'est ça c'est ce
que j'allais dire je m'en allais
directement le en fait on s'en remet à
la même place que d'évidence apprécié
qu'on se connaît mais il y en a qui ont
des pouvoirs comme ça c'est peut-être ce
qui me fait croire à ce genre d'histoire
le sait peut-être les espèces d'exemple
d'hypnotiseur c'est les espèce de truc
qui est quand même su conscient piller
que quand je jouais dans le cerveau de
ces pays et du monde qui sont pas wired
com com - les bretons mais l'hypnose si
oui ou non c'est vrai mais oui je sais
c'est vraiment vraiment accès à des
choses qu'on n'a pas accès tu écris le
masque derrière la maison mais en même
temps je me dis tiens je suis posté il
ya une faute au podcast avec joe rogan
dernièrement il parle pendant deux
heures et demie puis mais je me dis qu
as tu es quelqu'un de wii comme lui qui
voit le monde d'une façon et que ça doit
devenir lourd en sacrement est avec tout
mon tacle heureusement normal
un ver s est souvent le monde les plus
intelligents je peux dire qu'ils ont les
bleus sur les suicides qui sont
problématiques l'appui non c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais lui il utilise vendre
que demande de travailler genre 20
heures par jour puis des pas dormir puis
de manger juste des hot dogs
c'est toi je sais pas c'est quoi ton
rythme de travail mais je peux pas
soutenir un rythme moins longtemps que
je pense que mon nez de ce juste pété au
fret je pense que c'est un peu ce qui
est arrivé avec lui ouais mais j'ai
l'impression aussi moi plus que je
m'instruis moins curieuse
puis des fois je me sens un peu plus
nous parce qu'au québec tout l'été
réalité c'est extrêmement intelligent
non mais si je me dis souvent il ya
tellement de monde qui pensent que leur
problème c'est tout mais dans le fond
c'est rien piles et ça ça remet tout en
perspective tout petit je regarde
souvent du monde un peu niaiseux puis on
dirait que c'est justement le monde un
peu moins éduqués sont un peu plus
intelligent parce qu'on ne sait pas
pourquoi joe si comme on devrait comme
on est content c'est trop il ya trop de
mots leurs pieds excuse moi sans mal
d'être heureux ok le monde indique
qu'ils sont plus ou moins heureux mais
peut décemment
je vais à partir dans le certainement
quand et comme plus risquées en direct
non mais ça fait du change sa façon
par contre deux fois pas savoir ça
pétera dé prendre des décisions qui
montrent à tirer du malheur sais pas
comment tout ce qui mène certes mais je
sais pas andré je sais pas amener sa
terre sa tente de poursuivre c'est comme
il ya tellement de trucs et immorale qui
sont dans le monde puis on est tout
consommateur de ce que quand on est trop
conscient baisse atteint honte un peu
dans toutes les actions petit fait parce
que au bout de la ligne est américain
et on est jeudi on est américain c'est
pas un système qui quittait qui est
injuste
ouais exactement puis c'est nous qui est
un peu en haut de la ligne fixe et la
quiétude
on dirait que quand tu le sais trotter
est pas bien là dedans puis en même
temps tu peux vraiment pouvoir là dedans
non plus c est toi tu tentes à business
est ce que tu as eu des dilemmes moraux
sur lesquels tu as eu besoin de trancher
ouais moi y en a beaucoup qui vont juger
parce qu'ils savent que mes maillots
sont faits en chine
premièrement je tiens à dire qui est en
chine les conditions de travail sont
beaucoup mieux qu'ils étaient il ya
c'est donc bien de place oui si c'est
vrai on est en ce moment c'est comme
bangladesh pour tous c'est là que ça se
passe
métiers en chine c'est beaucoup moins
peut apprendre peut-être des villages
vraiment éloigné que mais au début
j'étais comme si je t'ai pas j'étais
jeune j'avais 18 ans quand je cherchais
mon fournisseur puis j'avais regardé ici
la bop ces différences de prix a pas
vraiment il ya beaucoup de lois pour
protéger les business d'ici donc
vraiment beaucoup taxe qu'en tirant
dessus puis des transports blabla mais
était il y en a qui veulent peuvent
consommer du over sea parce que si on
réussit c'est un peu mon blabla c'est
une bonne morale du tout mais
premièrement tous pas vrai que tout est
pas bon deuxièmement mois étant allé en
chine vis téléphones sont tous moi j'en
ai vu du linge et je n'aimerais pas
compagnie mais c'était écrit c'est au
québec dessus non plus pour qu'ils
s'acquittent chaque semestre suivant
pascal monde tchèques puis à personne
que tu t'en sms qui font six quais
mettons que toi tu es une personne viol
accompagné une mine compagne et mes yeux
la compagnie exquis et les fournisseurs
lambert le fond de ce soir va vendre à
toi avec les éducatifs et au québec
toi tu voles vont dans cette compagnie
le fait que s'ils arrivent de quoi c'est
toi qui te fait pogner cette compagnie
là ils peuvent en marc pascal dix ans je
savais pas mais aussi très bien que
s'ils allaient payer son tee shirt 3
pias parce qu'il détourne que tu es là
bas des tours mais moi il ya tellement
de l'argent qui lui même toutes les
bornes
c'est ça pitt et moi étant quelqu'un qui
voyage vraiment vraiment beaucoup je
peux si oui je vais encourager les
business du québec tous mes sponsors ma
plus grande valeur parce que je me
considère plus citoyen du monde lit
genre que citoyennes du québec ou du
canada
oui ce que si tu vas leur régime
espérait sûrement la plus importante
puis y est c'est pour moi d'acheter deux
des personnes qui font la pub je sais
qu'ils ont des bonnes conditions plutôt
parce que givenchy et on travaille tous
ensemble tout à fait sûr que si ceux ci
un dilemme moral au début parce qu'ici
je vais payer ces dames on y pense quand
on paye les waka deux pièces patients
finissent pas du pillage c'est très loin
de ce petit jeu mais j'aurais pu trouver
des maillots karité de piano mais non
c'est pas quelque chose qui me pousse
non il y en a souvent qui est mettons
quand on commande 500 hommes quand on
commande 10000 je dis ce n'est pas le
même prix par une plus grosse quantité
nous on en commet toujours plus depuis
le début et puis je fais le même prix en
ce moment que je payais quand jean
commandé 500 au début du repas ça m'a
jamais intéressé de faire comme si je
dis j'ai déjà ma marge de profit j'ai
déjà mes trucs j'ai pas eu besoin de
plus puis je veux pas non plus que ce
soit aux dépens de aussi lui car de
mieux payer ses employés parce que j ai
en produisent plus puissants fonds plus
bête en mieux piller
c'est cool ce cas me dicte qu'on se
marre comme citoyenne du monde
est ce que ta compagnie enregistrée au
québec ouais ouais quand même
mais si son pays
combien d'employés waka tension est
d'employer comme et employés employés
temps plein on en a quinze métiers je
pourrais aussi divisés c'est à dire
quand on est quatre comptables qui sont
à l'extérieur on est cinq avocats on est
si on est seul et comme c'est ce pas
compte et puis on a aussi les employés
en ira pour dans les entrepôts même nom
c'est quand même embêtant dans un
entrepôt entreposées 15 personnes à
zurich
hilton entrepôts et en estonie ouais on
en a ici bien en estonie que l'autre
fait nourrir en australie mais c'est ça
c'est sûr mais c'est sûrement dans quand
même temps et pour l'été prochain et
sera lille à l'été commence en australie
en ce moment l'année prochaine mais est
ici c'est un processus très long sur
main p4 ouvrir ça ça va ouvrir toutes
nos marchés nos fonds et on est déjà ce
marché là mais ce que ça va faire c'est
que ça va être juste mieux couru donc le
shipping va être moins cher mais aussi
quand ils vont recevoir les produits ils
n'auront pas à payer les taxes qui sont
très très cher payé ses caisses
cool c'est cool puis on et j'écoutais
l'entrevue tôt fait de break
la semaine passée le talent est là il
fallait que je veux c'est pour ça qu'il
voulait parler mais faut que j'en parle
qu'un qui dit il parle d' incorporer
toute l'ailé
tout les corps parlent et les diversité
corporelle fleurs il parle il parle des
maillots il est temps qu'ils rentrent
chez eux et dit mettez un tanga 225
livres de la corde dans la 205 emplois
moi je pars très bas et donc pas ce
qu'il fait exprès pour être la voix du
peuple
prends pas personnellement j'avais été à
donner les vagues 90 il m'avait dit pit
watts était anorexique te donne tu
d'accord il fait soleil mais aussi parce
que lui il pensait sans mentir dans le
fond lui si ce qu'elle montre comment
les acquis et non parce qu'à chaque
crise deux jours il capta frères ndama
parler à chaque jour youcam 4 sujets qui
n'ont aucun lien entre eux chaque jour
faut qu'il fasse ce qu'il faut qu'à
chaque jour ils jouent justement
l'avocat du diable y jouer il joue
qu'est-ce que manon qui habite à saint
georges à pense exactement c'est sûr
qu'il faut que pas aussi je suis pour la
bouche à oreille avec comme chaque avait
mis des photos puis que le lui faisait
l'avocat du diable parce qu'elle était
pas là s'était désisté dernière minute
puis non mais t'es cool mais tout ça
pour dire que ouais tu parlais et la
botte parlé d'ouvrir peut-être des
magasins mais pour flasher web est comme
ça c'est vraiment d'en monter quand je
dis je pense comme trois ans dans le
fond mois après avoir des entrepôts et
j'aimerais savoir des magasins pour
justement juste pourtant comme une
vitrine c'est que c'est pas
nécessairement magasin où je vais faire
plein d'argent qui est il que mon
rentrées d'argent plutôt parce que ton
sortant qui a en magasin il ya beaucoup
plus de dépenses puis ça fait
généralement moins d'argent mais les bus
ça va être vraiment d'avoir des magasins
d endroit cool pour que tim est aussi
j'ai au carrefour laval puis qu'il ya
personne dans le magasin dispose de
vanter comme y'a personne n'a qu'à citer
genre sur times square à new york
même si la personne dedans tu passes
devant accor est en cours à new york
c'est comme si tu vas mettre à réfléchir
à ses effectifs vraiment seul but de
juste part comme le web c'est psychol
c'est vraiment une bonne de était
justement à bali
quand on se prenait des rues on voyait
justement d'été des déchets à un gros
choc billabong qui tombe mieux de la
place qu flash à travers toutes les
et j'avais tchéquie pour avaler les lois
en indonésie c'est que tu dois avoir 500
mille dollars d'investir pour pouvoir
ouvrir une boutique à bob quand tu
trouves une boutique là bas c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment peu cher
quand je sens que tu ailles puis la pop
et compagnie font faire et leurs
produits en indonésie c'est un gros
surtout pour celle des sites investit
500 $ en indonésie pas couvrir un champ
de boue mais un vus qui font produire
leur produit là-bas bay ont déjà comme
si l'investissement est sûr c'est que
pour eux c'est vraiment facile d'ouvrir
une boutique lab option coûte rien mais
comme témoin mais mario sont peu fournis
ces fonctions sont un peu plus
difficiles toujours faisable mais
lorsque sa valeur d'un espèce de spots
lit vraiment puis aussi un hotspot pour
les maillots de bain vraiment comme il y
avait juste des 500 milles
mais oui il ya beaucoup de maillots de
bain sont scindés ni moins pire beaucoup
d'australiens qui sont en effet aussi
c'est à côté
c'est l'heure ouais mais ça c'est dans
trois ans que tu penses que tu as su où
situez c'était juste une espèce de raï
20 points soit vraiment qu'est ce que je
fais c'est minable moi je suis du genre
de nom mais comme si je me mets un but
de ce que je veux faire mais je me rends
toujours un peu plus loin mais mt avant
tout un peu et le masculin j'aurais
travaillé vingt heures par jour blanc
qui maintenant je commence un peu plus à
vivre jeudi le gros dos accueilli un peu
moins vite qu'avant mais je me permets
un peu plus et je pense que plus fine et
semble être la plus grosse compagnie au
monde
on se déclare mais ça c'est cool que tu
puisses faire ce c'est cool que tu
puisses juste prendre la peine de faire
ce que tu veux faire de voyager on en
parlait les ajustements de votre voyage
chez elle c'était quand on est juste que
c'est ça c'est cool que tu puisses te
permettre de faire c'est de partir que
des amis la piste on a parlé avec des
aussi de l'importance de vivre des
expériences ce que je travaillais
travaillait et les gens suivent aussi
parce qu'il t'aime toi tu es puis parce
que quelqu'un d'intéressant pis s'il
suffit pas d'expérience plus que juste
la compagnie l'accompagnait manip tadic
et les jambons un plus des intéressés
parce que toute autre chose à dire que
l'homme est en maillot de bain et jean
n'est plus tenu non c'est j'ai un peu
moins de photos en maillot de bain parce
que je sais qu'il y en ait si je fais ça
à l'année juste des photos en maillot de
bain le monde dont sécurité en ce moment
mais c'est un bon moment dans l'année
c'est pas mon meilleur moment de
promotion fait que je n'en profitaient
pour en ce moment fort apprécié fouet
tu fais tu es tu un peu tes stats
instagram to check je suppose et webedge
tchèque parce que ça fait partie des
cantons publié que c'est sincère je veux
dire probablement son public
il sentit d'hôtes est sensiblement le
même que le six mois même démographique
est ce que tu regardes comme au
quotidien mettons des abonnés ce qui se
regardent et
plus sur waka mai
je regarde mes seins plus un plus pas
mal à dire non non non on parlait
d'enfants qui disait parlant photo tous
nous y mettons c'est je pense que si tu
as des écueils aussi les gens qui vont
commenter quelque chose ça va être ce
qu'ils vont critiquer à prendre des
photos sexy web et y en a beaucoup qui
vont dire que moi mon travail si je
dépensais cac profite de son corps pour
vendre des affaires où nana na na na qu
est ce que tu réponds à cette critique
le aux gens qu'ils essaient faut qu à
être profite d'être encore pour vendre
des maillots de bain je dis non je
profite du fait que les gens ne
consomment que ce et qui était josé les
marketing au bout de la ligne c'est pas
la personne qui fait une publicité qui
décide c'est quoi c'est le monde qui
décident de ce qu'ils consomment pitt et
moi si justement ce que je fais beaucoup
sur moi un simple c'est que je vais
publier ce qu'est le monde consomme pas
ce qu'ils veulent c'est un peu du grand
du genre c'est juste que ça ait tenu
mais ce sera peut être pas sexuel non
plus parce que ça me ressemble juste
sexuelle c'est juste drôle puis et si je
leur donne est vraiment superbe si je
vends utilisé mais cap sont les endroits
où je peux m'exprimer en parlant que ce
soit nous tous mais story mais capitaux
pour faire comme est alors le genre si
toi qui a cliqué sur ma photo c'est la
raison pour laquelle tu es ici killer
c'est là que tissent pour ce que mon
instagram j'utilise vraiment moins cinq
ans pour envoyer le monde seront vacants
mais je connais ça m'a envoyé le monde
de wasquehal sûrement instagram parce
que c'est mon but est moins simple c'est
vraiment d'attirer le monde avec ce
qu'ils veulent pour apprécier de leur
faire passer le message de ça parce
qu'il y en a souvent ils essayent de
faire comprendre ce message le fouette
comme s'il faut être comme ça consomme
et s'appuie tout mais il utilise les
photos que le monde qui veulent que le
monde consommait si comme tu es mettons
le monde qui se paie n'y a pas de
diversité 60 jeux peuvent rayonner la
diversité son exemple si la regarde pas
c'est quoi c'est tout la ligen la
consomment peu non c'était exactement
fixée c'est vraiment comme d'emmener
dans mares et plus léger que c'est comme
si je veux dire ça à ces personnes là
bas il faut belgique le chemin avec eux
d'affronter au lieu de
davant juste la page oa qu est ce que tu
te la diversité méthode le thé tisane
sonne un peu tes amène le plus utile à
fait ok d'autres c'est raté c'est ultra
intéressant de dire de répondre monde si
ce n'est pas dix vérités sur instagram
qu' il y en a mais qui consomme pas si
c'est tellement bon non mais s'ils
quittent les gens et paulo puis s'est
quittés jeudi les photos les plus
cliqués pousser comme halo ballon mais
c'est évident c'est que depuis depuis le
début des d'instagram c'est le traîne
depuis ça continue dans ce sens là tout
une grosse différence entre mettons une
photo de toi habit vert c'est une photo
en bikini dans l'elite dit ça c'est sûr
que quand la faisait plutôt des foules
l'espagne et parce que c'est plus
provocateur mettant une photo en maillot
de bain avant ces big jo mais maintenant
disponible
c'est plus aussi spécial nancy 5e et et
je dire mettons tous regardés fille
alexis sur m6 mais des photos de leurs
fesses et en mettent tellement calme en
et ils vont ils y ont plus de like sur
leur sécurité parce que dans le fond ce
qu'il a été c'est souvent ce que tu
publies le moins fait que l'allemagne
ont une réaction
[Musique]
parce que là ça fait plusieurs fois que
tu dis qu'il ya plus en plus de montres
instagram puis que les gens qui sont le
plus plus longtemps ça fait qu'il s'est
dit lui un peu les gens vont moins tu as
marqué comme comme un cri tantôt didier
l'impression qu'à maintenir en avoir
tellement tellement qu'ils les métiers
d'influenceurs ça va pratiquement
disparaître parce que tout le monde va
naître baissent pas les serments
disparaissent c'est beaucoup plus dur
puis il va avoir beaucoup moins d'argent
là dedans
si je prends un exemple les parcs ont
été jeunes y avait
il y avait une crémerie à 56 jours un
petit village appeal a pogné puis et
ayant fait de l'argent que ça va coûter
pas juste un petit village comme emmener
tout le monde y voit sapin ils font de
l'argent blanc blanc bien opportune ou
et l'année d'après comme deux ans plus
tard il y en a cinq
j'avais pu une qui fait de l'argent
témiscouata sont pas bonnes autres
coiffes parce que m'emmener sisto peu la
même chose sur l éruption mais tenté
dans le chantier dans le temps me tende
et céline dion de quoi tu quelqu'un qui
te cas dans le jeu trine album il y en
avait pas beaucoup
secteur l album qui tous c'était plus
facile de percer métier maintenant il
n'importe qui font du rap l'yonne à
damas ces médailles en est tellement que
c'est beaucoup plus dur puis oui en est
qui font encore l'argent là-dedans mais
si ses gammes en est aussi ça devient
est plus difficile en ce sens que les
gens ce moment qui réussissent en
musique se passer du monde qui donne le
rôle de nora mondiale l'exemple que j'ai
moins c'est que probablement qu'au
québec mettons un influenceur dans leur
agent 120 et à saint-saud 10000 abonnés
à 20 occupation depuis qu'ils y aillent
cette personne qui arrive c'est huit
personnages bons tout dans fringe le 1
une journée probablement que les
influenceurs qui étaient là avant je
pensais à lissieu qui étaient quittes et
y avait plus que c'est un petit peu mais
dans un ring comme ça les gens quittent
à l'entrée en jeu du jour au lendemain
un boom dans nos huit autos québec qui
est un marché ultra petit fake
traitement que les prix ont descendu
énormément à l'été pour les absides
affaire le distance mais cette fois le
d'après moi pour au québec ça le fait
monter je sais plus exactement je pense
que les adultes se sont un peu plus
souvent ceux qui ont un peu plus compris
ceux qui les publient les gens qui
avaient des compagnies qui pouvaient
qu'avait d'argent pour investir dans des
gens et je pense que ça l'a un peu plus
ouvert le marché
les amendes argent
avec ça et puis maintenant j'ai
l'impression qui est peut-être le site
de contrebande ont intéressé mais
j'imagine qu'avec la prochaine vague
vraiment quilmes on va le savoir des
jeunes et plus en plus chez xo xo qui
embarque s'est plaint de télé réalité
s'il faut quand même le phénomène ces
puits mais j'en fais partie mais je
trouve ça quand même une scène était de
dire drôlement de même j'avais 360
abonnés sur instagram fait c'est un tout
nouveau monde mais effectivement vu
comme ça probablement qui allait ouvrir
plus les yeux aux gens que des
compagnies un peu plus vieille mentalité
ouais c'est c'est d'après moi ça l'a
fait ça puis le futur mans et sommes en
ayant les yeux déjà où va se reposer
mais non je suis papier t il ya aussi
une façon différente dans le sens qui
est votre pays et alicia m'a fait de la
même façon que le pays d'ici ou que vous
payez mettons mois ou de quoi parce
qu'on fait pas la même chose d'autre ce
qui est à l'essai à un certain prix
parce qu'à chante
vous avez un certain prix parce que vous
avez été à la télé
moi je veux avoir un certain prix parce
que je m'en mets fait ce qui est des
écoles non mais c'est vrai c'est comme
ceux des aspects qui vont faire que
quelqu'un qui paie pour la publicité
quelqu'un vous poney cent par rapport au
nombre d'abonnés si c'est souvent que
les gens et se trompe ou si c'est qu'ils
regardent juste le nombre d'abonnés mais
il ya aussi c'est pourquoi ils sont
connus à travers ce puits se dit que les
passages à dpa shao dfb en fait de phd
tout le monde nous dit et fait connaître
ces phénomènes le seul impression de ton
passage à tout le monde en parle aussi
sa fête
romain sa a fait connaître cette réalité
l'homme et aux gens qui avaient jamais
entendu parler de l'auteur est
probablement puis tout s'est senti en
avant et un après où change rien changé
pour toi ben moi ça aurait changé parce
que j'ai dit que je faisais pas de
promotion c'est sûr que oui j'en ai eu
lé comme des f-16 c/d as fait tes y en a
qui comprennent paul c'est comme ça je
te donne une montre le thé comme acquis
avez vous un budget mais on donne une
montre lamentable 200 pièces jeter comme
jamais me demande même toi tu as du
monde tu écrives sur moi et moi des fois
à petit les plus insultant c'est pas
quelqu'un qui te fait que l'agent plus
insultant c'est un peu insultant mais
comme tu es maintenant quelqu'un qui
arrive comme un cheveu dans 25 hier
c'était comme churchill
j'ai travaillé tout ce temps là pour 25e
mais tu vois je pensais même pas que le
monde shetty comme le monde propose ça à
moi parce qu'on en fait d'aimer le même
de gomez je vous donne mon ami mon
produit même ma sauce piquante à vos 25
pièces pitié mais c'est quand même moins
ça me surprenait pas vraiment de mes
tripes chamois mais quel monde tu écris
c'est à toi même après on met récemment
ils veulent pas manquer de respect à ces
charges juste pas et aucune des six
étapes pour réussir y impose qu'une
photo non c'est une publication savons
rien sur le web le 6 ème et ce qu'il
faut comprendre avec ça c'est qu'ils
tissent pas juste c'est non seulement
oui qu'est ce qu'ils savent alors sa
portée plutôt mexique et nous pas juste
de poster la photo si toutes les photos
qu'on a fait avant de façon gratuite on
les a faits pour pois et riz
après tout on ne construit que l'école
longtemps si on ne construit quelque
chose longtemps puis maintenant on
arrive à un certain point titre se paye
pas juste pour la photo qui a été
instantanée ça a été pour tout le
travail qu'on a fait avant s'est fixé
comme ce qu'elle a quittée crif qui
essaie de prendre par les sentiments un
peu de gens je commence je fais ça pour
une bonne cause une médina tout les
jours c'est normal puisque ray des fois
quand ceux du monde de ma ville où
quelque chose de plus les encourager
tous mais il y en a qui disent bel
devrait pas changer ce système le
produit oui je l'aimais si je commençais
à publier toutes les pratiques j'aime je
dis moi j'en concernent des affaires de
personne qui va aller travailler
gratuitement
c'est moi je fais de la musique dans
vicky georges tu as menti ça va être
gros deal it et vient faire un show
genre oui mais non c'est parce qu'il
sait pour l organisme est une levée de
fonds ça peut arriver qu'on en fasse
c'est ça peut arriver
c'est vraiment la cause et nous tient à
coeur ou que vraiment c'est la
visibilité
c'est sexy rock et les gens qui permet
de la visibilité si nous habiter
incroyable des fois ça peut l'être mais
mais c'est se tirer parti qui travaille
au gouvernement que le temps à cheval et
punchy et bénévolement aujourd'hui parce
que je supporte la cause des saints qui
soutient les artistes ou les gens qui
ont du travail un petit peu alternatif
c'est un travail commencé sa piété - la
plus et je pense très très rarement des
publicités sont moins simples la
complicité que je passe souvent ces gens
les compagnies de mes amis ou de
monomanie psy du monde que je connais
puis non j'ai charge peu parce que si du
monde que je connais mais de là à le
faire et à toutes les compagnies du
monde petits moyens nos soins qui me
disent je veux ton havrais juste envoyé
un cadeau non jositsch comme je le sais
que je les publie un peu parce que yes
pas je le sais qu'il aime tellement que
je vais le publier mais même si je les
aime tellement méchamment sens que je
vais pas achalés mon monde c'est comme
ça mais ça attire tous les requins est
ce que tu sens genre de moncton auto
pour avoir un petit buzz gratuit aux
gens
est ton ami mais est ce que tu as fait
le taf est juste pas des ânes et parce
qu'il est nos triomphes avec des
influences mais c'était je suis ta faute
j'ai fait un une publicité part à ce
coup récemment que et georges mais c'est
vraiment bien entendu avec eux plutôt
qu'ici on s'est rencontrés on a parlé de
leurs réseaux sociaux d'être quand même
effectivement des relations avec eux
puis sinon à part de ce jeu ctb parss
coin ce moment parce que c'était b 41
secondes
on sortait au starbucks était genre
l'est avait dit qu'il part à ce colloque
et puis je suis décidée ce constat était
persuadé que l'attentât ce qu'elle est
l'espèce des deux vagues 2005 qui en
2008 était quand même sinon de la
province de lahj un peu plus est - douch
le que c'était avant la moitié est pas
l'époque c'est dans le fond ça qu'il
doit c'est un chat ouest et les gains
qui sortent end automnal aux oscars avec
la gueule on s'était le board en
pyramide à québec
post-it que l'ex comme une grosse heure
un gros complexe
puis il y avait un diamant au meeddm
fermer à minuit les vendredis samedis
pour que le monde puisse aller au jam
descendre tout après encore gonfler
faire de line up a encore su alors dans
leurs jeans karachi qu à l époque
l'époque des douchebags est terminée ce
point de mauvaise
chose mais en le vide s'il a peut-être
moins vécu que nous le met et douche bag
sera garde à la québec
mais tout est quand même tranquille tu
me semble quand même tranquille de sap
ecc6 autant de gens nous parlent élisant
pour son est sorti et clientes pour ça
peut paraître conflictuelle quand même
votre relation d'amitié et ouais mais en
fait c'est vraiment drôle moi qui disent
on n'arrête pas de se dire la raison
pour laquelle on est autant amis c'est
qu'on est vraiment différente donc non
seulement on sent même une dans le monde
l'autre mais aussi et moi ce qui m'a
vraiment fait tomber en amour est
acquise entre je pense que c'était un
peu mutuelle ce que nous faisons n'est
pas compliqué fait deux matches on est
en voyage puis on dort dans une bouse de
vache on s'en fout si et nous devons
livrer dans ce sens qu'il ya pas de
mensonge et peu des genres mettons ces
réseaux sociaux va être la même personne
qu'on a oublié ses rires et puis aussi
si on n'est pas à la famille des abonnés
pour dire je pense que pour son
on s'entendait très bien mais ça c'est
cool quand même de pouvoir dire que tu
gagnes ta vie avec instagram mais que
des abonnés c'est injuste c'est un
chiffe c'est comme si quelque chose qui
trotte dans la tête tu veux pas chercher
à en avoir plus ne ferment tout le temps
tu sais plus ce métier si c'était en
fait si c'était juste de moi ça me
dérangerait vraiment peu plus que ça
parce que je suis pas une personne à
l'argent non plus surtout récemment puis
et mais là c'est juste que j'ai donné
des parents mon père puis à ma soeur
récemment de wata ouais
puis elle a enfanté m'ont pas lâché sa
job pour seulement 60 universités puis
est venu travailler avec nous que comme
c'est le copain de maçon et vient de
l'inde pied pour avançons vision langage
et parce que ça comprenez sais pas s'ils
y étaient rares voire un visa puis comme
le marais pour ceux aussi plus tu sais
j'ai tellement dépendants dans ma
famille autour de moi qui sont avec waka
que je ressens plus de pression qu'avant
commenté je peux pas juste faire comme
je fais une pause de waka pendant un
mois je m'en veux parce que ils roulent
pas sans moi c'est le ta vie personnelle
ta vie professionnelle sont entremêlées
ou si c'est vrai que s'ils arrivent de
quoi la vie personnelle que ça a fait
que la compagnie c'est comme ça devient
est ce que tu penses que ce que tu veut
séparer ces deux histoires l'eau ça va
toujours rester interconnecté pis mais
si je suis en train de séparer
tranquillement mais c'est sûr que moi
mettons et de me séparer avec mon homme
c'est pas juste je me sépare de mon chat
et déjà c'est quelque chose de difficile
parce que tu veux pas nécessairement
mais faut que tu ajoutes le fait que ton
essai en vo bce table sur pc et des
parents voire moins dans les faits le
cause à effet oui souvent à moins de
pique nique anti tabac avec toi ouais
parce que le monde sont vraiment reliés
à ta vie personnalités non c'est pas
tout le monde qui elle-même mais il y en
a que si vraiment ils ne vivent que pour
ton coupe fait que sexy c'est qu'il
devient disick enquille d'autres mondes
qui dépendent de ce parce que le sujet
c'est une décision des pertes subies
avec mon job je pas bien compte y sommes
c'est comme tout qu'est ce qui vient
avec maison mais si tu vois c'est de
travailler avec on en parle de mille
feux la musique avec sa blonde mais je
travaille avec jesse puis on en parle
souvent de deux heures c'est si
compliqué c'est complexe d'être embarqué
dans quelque chose avec quelqu'un piste
même si ça va
top bien là au moment où si tu prends
décision d'en marquer dans l'esthétique
tu prévois jamais prévoir le livre de
recettes qui vous sortez la est-ce que
vous avez signé n'attendent que vous
pour séparer avant que les sortes ou non
non on n'a pas signé d'entendre d'autres
sauf que si quelque chose qui était
arrivé pour qu'on te séparer ou laurier
passé par être qu'on aurait on enlève
rien dit jusqu'à dire que le livre sorte
qu' on aurait laissé vivre le livre un
peu avant de avant de l'annoncer
parce que c'est quand même pratique
courante dans dans la business mme est
ce parce que c'est des fois t'es pas
décemment près on en parle et wau ce
moment tu sais pas trop comment
l'aborder pis c'est comme c'est parce
que aussi toute une réaction quand on
vit un break up
la rupture est un hymne à la paix n'ont
cessé pitt et apprécié c'est comme tu
vires tomberait comme et en même temps
de sommeil appelée monde qu'ils jugent
tomberait capter moi c'était comme la
première fois je ne suis par lg entend t
on n'a rien dit sur nous on est juste
dit on n'est plus ensemble
tout le monde sait comment est-il le
tromper spéculer ips crédit etc c'est
dur d'avoir en plus mais t on s'entend
que c'est un choix non sens que tu ais
je le regrette pas non plus parce que je
sais que j'ai beaucoup grandi de soi
plutôt puis comme c'est il ya des plus
pire des moyens si ceux ci les moins
mais il ya beaucoup de plus poussif
imagine calais qui décident de juste
garder ceux complètement préfet mettons
que pino foncé sur moi j'en ai des amis
que son ex-femme leurs followers c'est
juste des gosses parce que mettre des
photos sexy tout jeune c'est quoi ton
pourcentage et moi c'est vraiment genre
c'est comme 87% fille betty j'ai tout
tenté en coupe puis j'ai comme des
discours que lego ont tendance à trouver
fatigant c'est la diversité corporelle
probable que les gosses c'est facile
c'est ainsi qu'avec les gars qui se
collent leur fait d'instagram qui ont
juste des as ils veulent pas entendre
parler dire qu'il aurait fait 87 pour ça
puis je défie deux voiliers des maillots
de gamme mais on l'aimé pas trop de
l'avant mais maintenant c'est les
maillots sont vraiment blindé comme et
tu l'achètes ces maisons c'est bon mais
surtout si sur instagram ces mêmes mais
la statistique je pense 615% de feuilles
sur instagram de tout le monde qui ont
un style qui ont l'application fait que
ce soit en 15 25 qui fait que dans ces
eaux là c'est comme il ya toujours tout
le temps plus est faible c'est sûr que
ton et holly primo il y avait 50 %
quasiment 2 go qui le suivait parce
qu'il a faim il ya plus de go que deux
philosophies wal aamal pourcentage
précis soit en pourcentage à 6 83 % de
filles mais c'est dur parce qu'il y fait
saisir pour un gode avoir beaucoup
d'abonnés aussi parce qu'elle m'a fait
suivre des filles plus cossus ce défi
c'est ça moi je pense que le monde qui
me suivent les filles qui me suivent et
me suivent pour leur show mode tant
qu'homme c'est la plupart de mon nom
mais c'est si long et si la plupart de
mes enfants loin en fait cédé des
blondes qui sont intéressés par le
véganisme excès du monde suivent des six
bleus qui me suivent - pour montrer à
leur chef cheikh qui fait ça il ya des
ados il fait de la course il s'entraîne
seuil est pas là je pense qu'il va curé
marylène janka ouais ouais c'est vrai
ouais en fait en amont la peau non elle
a pu mais ça ça reste un drôle de débat
est-ce que tu compares fais toi t es ce
que tu en vises et quand qu'il ya des
problèmes plus quel genre de monde qui
critiquait certaines façons de faire moi
je me sens visé mais peu jaser y aura
des bop
il ya toujours un débat quand ya pas de
bonne réponse gentille elle débat parce
qu'il n'ya pas de bonne réponse qui est
là l'addition d'opinion skrek je pense
qu'elle peut été particulièrement
respectueuse dans sa façon de le dire
mais bon c'est ça y est appartient
surtout que c'est quelqu'un qui était
connue parce qu'elle faisait des docks
de cul donc elle a été connu pour de la
sexualité gritti la sexualité pour faire
sa carrière donc pas de la même façon
mais quand même donc je pense que si ça
se prend toujours un peu moins quand ça
vient des quand c'est ça par contre sur
son point jeu des supports en accord ou
en désaccord je pense que c'est juste il
ya des gens qui utilisent leur corps
pour se sentir bien tendu qui en a
d'autres qui utilisent d'autres choses
qui sait si correct c'est juste qu'il
faut être respectueux en nous que vous
comprendrez deux façons de penser et
puis et c'est moi je comprenais thiam et
à me suis jetée comme dans ma tête
j'étais à le chaman fort peu ça la
dérange vraiment si c'est fait il ya
plusieurs questions d'environnement il
ya les questions de ce qu'on vient dire
ce que ça dérange vraiment choisi je
vais faire un petit peu un poster un
petit peu provocateur qui va polariser
parce qu'il est l'ultime ans a fait ce
qu'on fait là ça fait parler d'eux
puis il ya probablement un peu seul en
équation qui aussi bon c'est clair que
comme tu dis est pas de bonne réponse
puis qu'il ya vraiment les arguments des
deux côtés de la médaille qui qui valent
la peine d'être entendu je pense que
c'est une question de les raisons pour
lesquelles tu fais ce que tu fais c'est
peu importe c'est quoi ce qui est ce que
tu fais pour taymans six pays où tu fais
par pression sociale c'est peu importe
c'est que ce soit la fixe mais tout nu
intégral ou l'autre extrême ce soit la
personne qui porte
le voile intégral c'est dans le fond ce
qui est prestement le même débat déjà tu
le fais dessus par choix personnel tu
lui fais part prêts sont sociables et
sociales ancien bâtiment se cacher pour
la pression est immense montré pour la
pression c'est que c'est je pense que
justement il devrait pas avoir lieu à ce
débat là parce que c'est déborah qui
cause une pression sociale dont je pense
qu'on devrait juste y laisser les gens
faire suivre ce qu'on veut suis lié
ben c'est cela c'est cela répond je
pense à ces situations là c'est qu'il
peut prendre ton car tu peux juste
laisser le monde faire ce qu'ils veulent
exactement tout petit peu les seulement
parce qu'ils veulent si c'était
confortable de poster une photo de toi
en maillot de bain gauche ça te sentir
bien c'est émancipe s'il ya du monde qui
aime se regarder pillay et ben guidon on
s'en fout mais elle dans son que je
pense que c'est vraiment une question de
vouloir faire parler ou 8,6 je pense
qu'elle a commencé sa carrière en
faisant de le dd en étant controversé
puis je pense que ça continue comme ça
mais c'est la seule chose qui dérange
action pose c'est si l'attitude de ma
façon de faire est la bonne
ta façon de faire est pas la bonne c'est
tandis que c'est possible
sa façon de faire et ben carec puis la
façon de faire d'un autre bain caréco
cipi chacun fait ce qu'il veut s'y sent
bien là dedans la poste entend tellement
respectueux de leurs comptes je dis pas
que les arguments étaient mauvaises il y
avait une autre façon d écrire site ou
pis si je pense qu'aussi d'écrire de
cette façon là ça donne aussi une
mauvaise exemple des commentaires et
un jeu comme ça puis étaient sales pas
sa place le jeu dc on est en 2010 et le
respect de tous et chacun puis je dire
on supporte où se pendre supporter
supporter ma pomme est était pas obligé
de me dire à gdansk
c'est quoi le monde qui se donne un truc
c'est comme pour finir le podcast on
goûte au tchèque a dû libérer si oui
qu'est ce qui est annoncé qu'est ce
qu'on fait fait que ceux-ci notre synode
cheesecake vegan d'olive et gagnent les
pop l'at on jessy qui nous ont rejoints
pour goûter à notre à notre set dans
lequel gut s
et ça dis pas qu'ils émanent c'est bon
bon ok mais c'est bon le premier
commentaire par rapport à une pas qu'ils
aient même si bon elisabeth qu'est ce
qui s'est dit et c'est bon ça s'appelle
un commentaire c'est bon ould bah merci
beaucoup et j'avais hâte de nous avoir
accordé de ton temps puis piscine on
essaie se bat tout le monde a le moins
bonne façon de finir la casse
[Musique]